what about the music on this stage uh
dude when they the like is upstairs then
they go down dude i absolutely love it
it this this for me is this stage is
like an ode to tech and fall in the the
wondrous days of tech inside batsu combo
videos
with deru playing all over it like this
is just a beautiful stage i'd love to
see more stages like this there's some
you know
this versus g
g cup helipad at night i mean really is
there even a comparison
shove straight away oh strap into the
back one too though very interesting
how many king players do the new back
three the hulk hogan low drop off of it
now
it's so good because you get back to
nokia as well if you go for it and the
just frame isn't really much of a just
frame it's worth going for it all four
again greetings starting off on the
front foot against mob maybe he has his
number that's what punished punish that
oh okay
goes to the unblockable greetings is
having none of it with their downford
one now cracking him in the skull for
even trying it i like it down forward
two
regular throw broken
and for a huge ddt but nice block but no
launch by greetings the curse of the
king player is to do a while standing
two two when you should launch but he
would stop that that was a great step on
the dynamic entry and we're going to the
wall as well
shiny wizard
and once you didn't finish it
okay so it finishes it all right this is
mob's chance should be able to go to the
wall but doesn't want to new razor he
can break the balcony
i think he does that use his tailspin
yes it did though
oh the raw unblockable but he catches
him floated
mob is angry right now but it's not
enough to win in the round
that's the great thing about kings at
forward three if you go for it and you
get jabbed out of it you're at a weird
angle if there's not much they can do
it's such a good round ending
okay a mob should be able to carry to
the no again goes for the spike regular
throw not broken that's huge for mob
what's the follow-up here
nice patience by greetings
one two one okay
crouched asheville stunning two two yep
okay doesn't get the wall
regular throat broken
oh big whip another punishment yeah
while setting 2-1 season 4 buff the
second it is now a count to hit launcher
i just say i hate that by the way so
many strings the second it just has to
become a canon launcher
all the second hits are made where it
used to be a high that's that's
challenging yeah that last is down for
2-1 yeah
speak of the devil
there it is
even when you scuff it goes for the good
oaky doesn't quite work out
okay looks like it could go to final
round number four regular throw broken
this time raider in all the greetings
nice interrupts doesn't want to take the
throw two one doubled one nice nice
there by mob he's alive
patience here from greetings for neutral
two
four four two from large yes the county
should carry to the wall as well yes he
does
nice go for the fancy combos again the
ford ford two gets the wall splat very
nice by mob
not gonna kill her but he can put
himself in a killing situation running
three
now forward one this is looking like
mobs round back one keep out
has to do so much here i get the thing
you might go for a chain grab oh no
muscles
look at the wave dash by greetings
really strong movement still wasn't
enough
what a game though that was great
i mean mob look this has been mobs
factor we've seen it so well it's just
his adaptation that was a mid-game
adaptation there but early will start
against stroke losing that first game
goes to the infinite starts making the
comeback knows what he needs to do moves
around him well now in this game just
mid game realizes what he needs to do
switches up makes greetings come to him
and he takes his first i mean he got his
first round on greetings earlier but now
he has his first game over greetings and
it's a great start here in this loser's
final
yep look very strong had made some
really good guesses at the wall and also
i think we saw it a little bit when
greeting was playing its kuna mitsu
before he gets bumblebee there were a
few times where he got hit with a one
two and he was caught pressing buttons
straight again after trying to steal his
turn back and i got the thing that mob
uh caught on to that and started uh
locking him down even more um i don't i
don't think greetings greetings needs to
change much though he played pretty damn
well yep it just came down to mob in the
end just you know getting going whoever
whoever gets started first has been the
10 of the tape for today in general
whoever gets started going first is the
one who normally takes the rounds so the
interest see the uh the adaptation here
we're probably going to see the
forgotten realm again
um because you know we've seen how much
greetings like that and there it is
there it is
it hasn't always worked out though from
the perspective of getting the floor
breaks we haven't seen a single like big
floor break juggle or anything like that
really for him so
uh is it going to come back to bite him
i guess we'll see
last is okay on this stage too
so we we saw this early with bumblebee
lars is
small mob's uh job here so just kind of
break the floors before greetings does
every launch every touch every
opportunity he gets he just wants to
take away that nice but the first one is
going to go to greetings
oh yes he keeps it he went big he went
for the headbutt on the wall the wall
throws um if he'd done that then he
would have gone through the floor again
okay two one yep breaks the first floor
very smart
water like it
oh catches green pushing buns
should have tried to break the floor but
it's okay
nice in the back very nice there mob
being very aggressive now forcing the
issue
and again it ends out very nice start
there by mob with the down two one
okay this time he breaks the floor i
assume he was keeping it last time
because he just wants more damaging
options with the floor break right yeah
i think so yeah and he did try and break
it with the wall throw but if your
opponent's aware of that on this stage
again it comes back to the fact that
you're making your options about the
stage rather than about what's what you
the opponent is thinking
locked
off around his gun right now
very patient play from greetings here
oh my goodness the 442 though expect him
to say that doesn't work out
nice the lightning screw out of noah i
respect the attempt but doesn't work out
this time
if you're gonna do it you might as well
do it with zero health
running through the first rooms
running through on the plus stream
said it so many times now four forward
one of the damage keeps doing running
three
and there's plus frames
oh tried to whip on it it doesn't work
out shiny instantly not broken
yeah broken shining wizard into giant
swing mob was aware of it walking back
now are we seeing a decent
there's something funky is going on
right now
i don't know
this video could be a dc i don't know
something funky is happening maybe mobs
playing the mind games right now as the
life deficit this is risky though with
the life deficit not doing anything
i think it's an odd decision to just
stand there and do nothing and just like
their greetings will take the round
let's see what happens this round look
like it was a decent to me
just walking back maybe we i think we
might have some kind of hardware issues
uh between the two um i believe mob
plays on stick could be some stick
issues from what was going on there like
he was just holding back i don't know
we'll be getting something uh
concrete for you guys soon and we'll
find out what happens but yeah i mean
we're seeing already um i like what
greetings is trying to do you know when
he's getting low parries on that stage
he's electing to go for as much damage
as possible to make those floor breaks
count um i did want to see mobs sort of
uh play it put more emphasis into the
breaking the flaws
um rather than just like getting the
damage because king is so good he's so
good on the stage so yes yeah i agree
with you yeah and mob does you sick he
uses the same stick as me and without
plugging that stick i'll say it's as
sturdy as an astro headset so oh
what's going on are they back in
i think so it's a final round
find a round situation
and this could be the round shoulder i
don't know
no yes he gets him okay so we did have a
decent we switched to backup production
standards here we get you the game no
matter what and we get you the result
wow
okay
that
phenomenal all right okay
this this is this is when we know we're
in the absolute peak of online tech and
production standards is that we still
managed to get the result of the last
second
and it looks like he took it
we had we had a situation at that once
in icfc uh in a final round situation um
the game because obviously because you
have two people in the dobby one is the
backup and then one is the actual uh
what we're seeing the stream from uh we
stopped on one the there was a desync on
one of the on the regular ones which are
we can't see anymore and production
switched to the backer like straight
away and as i always see the gaming
right right immediately so production is
really on point when it comes to these
things this is the future
of uh of second you know or online
viewing experience
you know like you still get the result
and just like that
uh it is now all tied up one one
uh
i'm it's a bit jarring so i'm trying to
figure out like what happened there
we're just going to see stage ping pong
surely now that's what it's going to
come down to
we're going to go infinite uh back to
the realm infinite maybe again realm
again depending on how it goes
surely that's how it's going to play out
now yeah especially it's going to be the
infinite going around if we're going
from infinite realm until it's over so
whoever wins this next game puts himself
in a great position because if it does
go down to a final game they will pick
where the final match happened we've
seen on that game there mob is still
pretty confident and comfortable on the
forgotten realm he knows what he's doing
is using like back uh backboards he
wants to break the floor and stuff like
he's just he's ready for it so
it'll be interesting to see how how they
make the adaptations throughout the
stages you know because uh the first
thing was island paradise and when you
break the balcony of island paradise is
a very big stage i think it's
i think it's the
i think between that stage and the
broken uh wall on you know when you
break you break the break the balcony
and then break the wall and jungle that
post i think those are two of the
biggest stages in the entire game those
broken floors um so it almost simulates
the infinite stage for a but you get to
see with all that movement around how
much you can play with it so
mob had time to uh to gather data on how
the big stage the almost infinite works
out for him so let's just see what he
chooses here does he stick with his
tried and true infinite yes he does the
art to snowfall the russian stage
now it's one it's one a piece but i
think it's an arguable that mob has made
better use of the infinite stage over
recent games than uh greetings has made
of the
the the floor break stage i think
he won that game but he didn't get many
of the breaks that we saw whilst we were
watching the game
um so i would say that the momentum for
me despite uh just losing that game by a
hair
it is with mob yeah i do have to agree i
feel like uh greetings almost picks like
the infinite stage sorry the forgotten
realm as like a default thing it's what
you're supposed to pick as the king
player rather than having stuff ready
for it
nice just frame gets okey went for the
forward two you can get so much from
that scenario
oh man this is that nice
relatively even unhealthier we're gonna
throw broken
we're gonna throw broken right back
definitely a scuffed shiny wizard
oh lovely duck into launch
that was incredibly quick what's the
oaky no i don't impress yeah he was
ready for that great art bus
just trading a little bit here
two running knee
follow up
that knee is not plus despite looking
like it break g cleft cabin right there
by mob nice stuff
it should be the round for lmg more very
nice
look at this he's so he just plays so
well on that infinite stage he does he
speed he's speed running him right now
all doesn't break the giant swing
slow
as he is
we take this
nice punish
he's taking a page out of strokes book
with those art glasses
locking him down with the jabs
i punish
great low parry there by greetings and
this could be the round if he plays this
right it should be
okay
gets on the board was looking very
one-sided until then
oh my goodness another one
has he got a read on him mob is not
breaking these drag queens
oh no
pick up get back break it back break it
right no no okay
back one two greetings making the
comeback here we we see mob doing this
[Music]
nice break one plus two throws
up knee no punish by mob though
[Music]
didn't commit
okay the race drive gets the flow
yeah that wasn't the best situation
though
not broken though enrage
mob can take this running explode off
nine seconds left
can greetings steal this one
five seconds the while 72 is getting
back
two seconds down three though all the
time back that's gonna wait yes it's
time
oh
that was
there was still time
dirty wizard we still have to compensate
this
one
that one two punish that
it's very important to duck that second
hit and get a launch
we'll break the jazz swing this time
start breaking one
his friend nice break on the
[Music]
running three
okay i'm just now these guys are getting
nervous now over tall
okay 12 seconds left
we're not going to see a repeat are we
surely not surely not
with the tanker i could have locked him
up five seconds four seconds left
running forward down back four two
seconds oh
that's the wrong
time
yeah that was the wrong time for that
move and
with two more seconds on the clock that
would have won in the game
but wow
it was interesting i wonder what he was
going for
it was just the wrong time for that that
i mean any throw because king king's
throws do take a while like you know we
did something like tombstone especially
just like muscle buster there wouldn't
have been enough time that the clock was
ticking down and you wouldn't have
enough time maybe like maybe tijuana
twist would have worked but
would have definitely got him but that
was he that definitely wasn't the input
he was going for i actually can't think
what he was going for there if it wasn't
that's right um so interesting enough
time
for him to uh to close it out there and
take it so yes 2-1 now to lmg mob but
greetings is keeping us very close we're
probably gonna go back to the forgotten
realm but
i'm i'm excited something exciting at
this point i mean greetings is making
this one a real game
he really is and he hasn't even done one
tombstone into max damage juggle on
forgotten realm he hasn't done one
muscle buster into max damage there's
this the law of averages says it's gonna
happen i wonder if it's gonna happen
this next game these games have been
closer than than i would have expected
on their native stages we just we caught
the end of that forgotten realm state uh
match it was a sliver of health that
game went down to the absolute wire as
well we've been really in for a treat
from these guys
now here is the forgotten realm
has a job ahead of him if he can win
this game your huge statement exactly
what he needs to do
all right if i'm in mob shoes it isn't
the worst it isn't the worst case
scenario
because even if you lose this we go back
to the infant and we have seen mob so
constant on the infinite stage out
playing strong on the infinite stage in
the mirror and against the steve so
greetings is really the one who has to
force the issue right now
again a love chat we must have had some
problems
punish that
not broken to the wall yes
even
more
this surely won't do it break the floor
oh my god yeah he can't that's dead no i
will break again
round two
fight
i think honestly i think i think too
many hits i think if if mob did less
hits in that combo and then spike
that was guaranteed but mob doesn't let
that face him down four two one
all the fancy combos you love to see it
i love the way the mob's been using jab
and down forward one just to lock down
the movement and stop all the chain
grabs being really good
i can work out taking a page out of
strokes but breaks the throat this time
oh but the hot knee doesn't can this is
going to be around two rounds up for
greetings he's playing this stage so
well
he is indeed but we saw it in the last
game anything can happen if you can come
back oh it doesn't convert it into a
battery really needed to do that that
would have put him in a prime position
or three looking good breaks a giant
swing that was important super important
mob should have this round down for one
and that's the while 72 he's staying
alive right now
these two are giving us one hell of a
game right now
mob needs two rounds to end it greetings
needs one more round just to elongate it
just for one more game
oh what a response
i start close
what you want no doubt
all right one two
four three
i like this he's going for the shove
slows them down a little bit every time
you shove them you're slowing them down
again
again needs to switch it up they're
becoming a little bit predictable oh
giant sweet again that would have been
dead nice break
finish is it i like that option break
the floor immediately as well no more
floors left in play so smart by mob even
if the combo isn't the best but big ones
available no it doesn't use it
okay
i've got one g-clef doesn't finish it
oh my goodness oh my god oh my god he
crushed him
but it was he was airborne it didn't get
anything he was airborne
four seconds he needs something big that
he can't do it
budget hell sweet
you know what
i i knew he would do ford 4-3 there i
feel like that was the obvious choice to
go for you need a big mid but you need a
big low you need big damage to go for
you should have just done another low i
think i think he should have just kept
the lows coming because he had nothing
to lose and oh my goodness he got very
unfortunate he did the lightnings
through it when underwater upwards as i
went under ford fought but because it
was floated he couldn't get a combo
maybe he did often in four i don't know
um but yeah that was that was insane and
now we have a final game between
greetings and mob way closer than their
winners semi-final match way closer i've
got i've got to disagree with you he was
foot unfortunate without 4-3 i mean come
on
it pushed forward four
i mean how on earth does it crush that i
listen it that move goes under literally
all of my miss so i'm not surprised it's
time for it it's time for other people
to to go what i do feel that pain yeah
i'll get it i get it
yeah that was a surprise i think he even
surprised himself or maybe that was why
he didn't fully convert it he didn't i
think whilst that informed me the
problem is because he was floated that's
not a situation you get very often a
float using a lightning screw so maybe
he was just expecting oh my regular he
just did what he regular combo maybe he
did think he was fluid i don't know um
while 74 was the smartest option to go
for because obviously it's the the most
uh they've got the biggest hitbox of all
the moves the lowest hitbox as well so
it could have worked
unfortunately but it is fine because mob
goes back to his patented arctic
snowfall and he plays so well on this
stage
sweaty palms and squeaky bums it's gonna
be too all one of these guys is going
out and the other one is going through
to the finals
all right they're down back four
again four four four three plus four on
here big chunky move
nice and shiny wizard very strong at
i was very hard there
nothing two one
one more hit does it here for mob
a rage available for greetings just one
touch and that could have been it
round two
he'll be frustrated there unfortunate
down four two into giant swings broken
again needs to mix these things up and
he does
oh but a full crash downpour too the
first time that has counted all day but
no drops the
all right combo the full crash low
what you should do now if you're mob
three
four four four four three again got the
plus frames going
plus two let's break
for the style points as well we're all
tied up here in the final game
this is it the winner of this game
whoever gets two more rounds moves into
grand finals on the loser's side secures
themselves 200 points minimum moving
forward on the leaderboard d-clef cannon
oh look at this now mob is feeding
himself the shadow step is coming in oh
[ __ ]
oh the step into the start orbital very
nice i think this is the round as well
for mob this is
this is this set point right now for
mobile to grand finals lose the side
carried him into second tax three
unbelievable
now he's got two rounds to win this or
he's going to be going out
punish that 1.443 again greetings is not
blocking that at all while standing 2-1
back four count hit but it's a trade no
throwing it
that'll be it surely
mob all aggression while standing two
one ends it out and mob moves into grand
finals losers side